SCHEDULED THIS AFFECTIONS
HEARING WE JUST HAVE ONE BILL
ON THE COUNTER DAY WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY WE
CURRENTLY NOTICE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM SO. WILL BE JUST BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. SECRETARY
PLEASE VISIT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS
SPECIAL HEARING TODAY FOR MY
ONE BILL. SB SIX NINETY IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE WITH ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS ADDED TO ALLOW AYE
PHARMACY THAT IS DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED IN AN EMERGENCY. TO
QUICKLY REESTABLISHES ITSELF IN
IN A NEW LOCATION WITHOUT
HAVING TO RESTART THE FULL
LICENSING PROCESS. AS IF THEY
WERE BRAND NEW PHARMACY. THIS
LANGUAGE IS SPONSORED BY THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY AND CONTAINS
AN URGENCY BECAUSE OF THE
POLICY WILL BE IN PLACE FOR
THIS FIRE SEASON. WHEN YOU
VOTED ON THIS BILL THE LANGUAGE
IS LIMITED TO CODIFYING
REGULATIONS RELATING TO TELL
THE PHARMACY AND ITS
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS LANGUAGE
IS STILL IN THE BILL AND THE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN
STRAIGHTENED STRENGTHENED BY
THE SENATE. THESE CHANGES TO
THE PHARMACY TO PHARMACY LAW
WILL HELP THOSE INVULNERABLE
AND RURAL AREAS ACCESS PHARMACY
CARE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME I HAVE WITNESSES. SURE
WE'LL BE REALLY QUICK MISSY
JOHNSON HERE WITH NIELSEN MARKS
WERE ON BEHALF OF CARDINAL
HEALTH CARDINAL IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA C.
PROVISIONS. THESE PROVISIONS
WILL HELP IMPLEMENT PREVIOUS
SPOT THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
IMPLEMENTED DUE TO THE LACK OF
REGULATIONS AND WE RESPECT LAST
YEAR I VOTE. GOOD MORNING
MICHELLE RIVAS WITH THE-
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION. ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE'RE
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE
DESTROYING THAT PHARMACIES WITH
FIRES THAT ALLOWS FOR
CONTINUITY OF CARE AT THE
PHARMACISTS ARE ALLOWED TO JUST
TRANSFER THE LICENSES TO NEW
FACILITY RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIGHT ABOUT. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. CNN ANY
MEMBERS OF POLITICIANS BEGIN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND NO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AT ALL.
AND WE WILL TAKE UP THE THIS
ITEM THEN WHEN WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. OF COURSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS
WILL JUST HOLD TIGHT AND TILL
WE OURSELVES A QUORUM AND THEN
WILL VOTE AND THEN GET ON I
MERRY DATE
. BREAK A COMMITTEE
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. LOW
HERE BROWN'S BLOOM. ARAMBULA
CHAN YOU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG
GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE TING. OKAY NOW WITH
THIS AS A QUORUM THIS IS THE
BILL BEFORE US DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND. YES MOTION
AS I CAN CONSIDER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
MUCH IS A RECOMMENDED SITE
MINUTES BECAUSE HEARD IN LOW
LIGHT WELL I PRO. ARAMBULA
BLOOM WHEN I CHEN GEN I CHILL
TO AYE CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN EGGMAN
AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GLORIA
GRAY AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE REALTY
I TING. THE BILL HAS A TEN
VOTES AND WILL THOSE THAT DOES
HELP BUT BELIEVE IT WILL OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. THANK
YOU
. SIXTEEN OKAY THE VOTE IS
SIXTEEN THERE THE BILL'S OUT.
OKAY OKAY HARD PERSON TO LIVE
DELIVERY. YOUR HEAR BACK FOR ME
I'M NOT LEAVING THIS